at this level you know don't be afraid
to
to go for something like this if you
know what you're doing right don't play
a move like knight g5
just because it looks cool
make a move like this when you have a
very specific aim in mind such as yeah i
want to take on e6 i want to eliminate
the light squid bishop and then i want
to attack the pawn that's going to be on
that weak square
[Music]
let's do a a reduced let's do a game
light
you know let's do a game where we don't
analyze it quite as deeply if that's
fine with you guys and we'll do a
10-minute game with no increment
okay
um soupy
thank you
let's go e4
e6 so french
and you guys already know those of you
who've watched the speed run for a while
know what i do against the french
and i play the gionatus variation
um peter actually introduced me to it
and we're gonna play it again okay no
we're not because white's gonna play a6
that is not
a move that you see every day although
it is a move believe it or not a6 is is
a move
now
when you face such moves there's nothing
in particular that you should do you
should simply develop your pieces so
knight f3 seems very reasonable here not
knight c3
because we want to be able to play c3
when the moment is right
c5 okay
so black is trying to transpose the game
into a con sicilian i mean if we play
knight c3 here black takes on d4 and we
have a transposition but of course
we are not going to play knight c3 we
are going to punish black for
this amount of pawn moves how do we do
that we play principal chess
we push that pawn down to d5
and this is almost like a benoni
structure but black has lost a bunch of
tempe on weird pawn moves
and you know this could get very
problematic if black is not super
precise
in such positions knight f6 okay
i mean that's a reasonable move
that's a reasonable move um
but we defend the pawn knight c3
[Music]
not 95
because that drops
that drops the pawn on d5 and d6 which a
lot of people are tempted by in such
positions as premature because then we
drop e4 and we're going to lose the d6
pawn
okay
we're going to lose the d6 one
d6 that's a good move i was really
hoping that he would go he takes d5
which would be wrong
now there's multiple ways to play such a
position with white and don't feel like
white is winning or anything white's
just solidly better but it's not like we
are you know in
amazing you know it's not like we're
winning now we have a positional
approach and a more tactical approach we
can take on e6 and keep the center open
and white is better white is definitely
better
um so we can kind of go after him here
and i think given that we have a lead in
development it makes sense to do that
the other approach is to play the
positional move a4 preventing of course
black's main idea which is b5
it's largely a matter of taste but i
you know
i feel like with white we should go for
a more principled approach let's play t
takes e6
now what should we do in this position
of course we can develop we can play
bishop f4 bishop g5 but i'm giving you
guys a hint by talking about principled
play this might not be the best thing
that we can do
but
i still i feel like playing ambitiously
here really trying to punish black now
e5 d takes e5 leads to an end game
that's not what we want
that's not what we want
we want to make a move that in many
cases is extremely superficial and i've
discouraged against this particular move
in many types of positions but in this
situation this move has a very specific
aim in mind
uh to to destroy black's pawn structure
to get rid of this bishop on e6 and
that's the move knight g5
but what do we want
we want to take the bishop on e6 and at
the end get the bishop out to c4 and hit
it hit him where it hurts on that e6
bond and if the bishop moves away then
bishop c4 is going to be
totally crushing that threat against f7
is going to be incredibly nasty
knight g5 might not be the best and i
think that if i were playing black here
i would simply develop with knight c6 i
wouldn't go h6 because such moves are
bad because we want to take the bishop
anyway right
so it doesn't make sense to go h6
furthermore it weakens this diagonal at
the end
yeah bishop g4 and bishop g4 is not not
a dangerous thing we go f3
or we could even go
bishop e2 and trade the light squared
bishops and then we have
very nice control of the d5 square
what should black do here as i said i
think knight c6 is the best move
uh b5 could also be considered though
it's very dangerous to continue not
developing
i think we have multiple ways to punish
him for that
i would i would uh
go knight c6 here and then knight takes
c6 f takes c6 we're gonna play bishop c4
and white is better
but the game is not over instead he
blunders
instead he blunders a piece i mean this
walks right into of course 1966 and
we're gonna win the night i think he had
internet problems that might have
distracted him
and yeah this type of play often works
so
at this level you know don't be afraid
to
to go for something like this if you
know what you're doing right don't play
a move like knight g5
just because it looks cool
make a move like this when you have a
very specific aim in mind such as yeah i
want to take on e6 i want to eliminate
the light squid bishop and then i want
to attack the pawn that's going to be on
that weak square
yeah black can try queen h4 but then we
go g3 hitting the queen and preventing
checkmate
and if black plays queen f6 we have
multiple moves including the simple
queen takes g4 anyway
yeah i think he might resign
okay knight f2
yeah so
what's the let's try to be accurate here
i think a lot of people would just
instantly grab this
we have a fundamentally we have a choice
we can play knight takes d8
and simplify into an end game up a piece
we can play
king takes f2 but we have a third move
and i think that third move
okay so he ends up disconnecting
i think that third move is even more
accurate though
and what am i talking about
no not queen f3 well queen f3 i like
also because then we can take with the
queen on f2 and we um
we preserve the right to castle
i like the move queen h5 pinning the
pawn really going for the most going for
the throw
we're pinning the pawn we're still
attacking the knight and we're attacking
the queen
and after queen f6
rather than knight c7 check which i
think is not the most accurate although
still completely winning there's a very
typical concept in such positions which
wins on the spot what am i talking about
95 boom
and of course if queen e6 then knight c7
wins the queen
so
multiple ways to win in this position
but in any case i think when h5 ends the
game anyway
not much to talk about here this is just
bad opening play by black
um the one thing i will say
is that against
against uh he takes d5 who can tell me
the proper approach here and this is a
common common oversight at the lower
levels
yeah g6 maybe keeps black in the game a
little bit longer i agree
yeah and that's e5
and then i've seen this so many times
people will often play d4 and if you'll
feel cool
but white wins a piece here ef6 dc3
and now there's a cold shower waiting in
queen e2 check
right and the spawn in f6 is defending
e7 this is
you can win win a bunch of games like
this or or queen takes c7 just force the
queen straight
and if white or flat goes 94 then knight
d5 is a total disaster i mean you're
going to go bishop d3 and the knight's
just going to be trapped there white has
a big lead to develop and a positional
advantage so just file this away into
your mental directory that you you never
should just automatically recapture in
the center these moves that push the
pawn forward
can be very dangerous
okay so d6 we decided to take on e6 the
approach alternate approach was a4
which leads to
this type of structure i once lost a
game like this with black i used to
experiment with the move c5 here with
black
and there was one game where i just got
crushed in this structure i just was
incredibly cramped the whole game
and um
and i ended up kind of getting pushed
off the board and this really soured me
on this line
um
i i don't have the game in the database
but
in any case uh this is just not not very
fun
okay
and that's going to end the stream for
today guys what incredible support thank
you so much that was phenomenal
um i might play play a couple more blitz
games afterward but
i'm just gonna and do some puzzles just
as a warm-up so tomorrow i am doing
puzzle battle world championship at 12
p.m noon eastern time
uh so feel free to tune in i'll do my
best can't guarantee that i'll qualify
and if i don't qualify i will be
commentating the ensuing rounds thank
you guys so much
thanks for hanging out wonderful
wonderful stuff thanks again a ton for
all the support
see you guys tomorrow
[Music]